The biggest difference between
volleyball and volleyball is that volleyball is a
hand exercise, and the condition is
that it is a movement with the feet, and it
feels like the main character of wealth
.
[Music]
Ugh, my name is Won Lee Kwang-jae. The
team I belong to is Joy Kicks
Sports, and I have been playing for 15
years.
There is a record of hitting the mat and weaving straw or grass to make a ball and pass it over
[Music]
This is in line with the unified rules and
pots frame due to
modernization.  A
total of 8 players play the game
. When our team
passes the ball to the opponent's camp through the server or attack, the opposing team does
not pass the ball to our 3d touch Suahne Kim Jin-young. The
monopoly is recognized
except for football  The
attack techniques are divided like this
.
[Music]
So far, most of the conditions
are close to play,
but based on the excellence handed down by the old ancestors
, it has been inherited and developed a little more, making it
a popular sport that is not inferior to soccer or baseball or basketball
.  I wish I could develop a little
[music]